en ligne avec amadou boubacar cissé ex
premier ministre du niger dans le camp
de l'opposition
bonsoir à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france est-ce que les
nigériens ont voté massivement notre
invité tout à l'heure nous a rapporté un
engouement des électeurs
est ce que vous faites le même constat
oui je pense que les ligériens selon
saad et à ses participants bien entendu
avec les contraintes sécuritaires qui
lie à parce que aux dires que la
vendeuse en importante en tout cas la
sécurité n'a pas pu être assurée et
malgré le fait que beaucoup se sont
déplacés il a aidé des attaques ou des
deux attaques qui n'ont pas pu permettre
aux crises
alors justement vous avez vous été
plusieurs fois candidat à la
présidentielle cette fois vous avez
retiré votre candidature au profit de
l'ancien président mahamane ousmane
qu'un autre opposant à soutient
également à mamadou on a l'impression
quand même que l'opposition elle a peiné
à présenter une candidature unique
pourquoi n'y a pas eu de candidature
unique pour contrer justement le
candidat du pouvoir mohamed bazoum
écoutez vous savez nous sommes où nous
sommes plusieurs leaders de kiki son qui
ont un certain nombre d'heures de
positionnement député l'otan vont nous
n'avons pas pu arriver au départ à avoir
le consensus sur une candidature unique
le pire que j'aie ans parce qu'il était
mieux que chacun dans son camp et
dansant dans son fief puisqu'elle met de
mobiliser le maximum de voix et de long
de leur tour et au second tour alors
évidemment on se rend bien compte que le
pouvoir tente son fameux coup ko qui est
absolument impossible d'abord parce que
aucun parti en hiver
je ne peux faire encore tout seul le
pnds qui en perte de vitesse énorme
puisque après dix ans le pouvoir de
pouvoir très très mal perçue par nos
populations ce que les ligériens ont eu
la conviction que c'est un régime pied
qui eux il ne s'est pas occupé de
l'intérêt général n'est plutôt de de
créer le camarilla qui situe préoccupe
essentiellement d'une gestion partisane
du pays damas ils ne peuvent pas
il y est elle est faible il ne voit pas
très bien moins d'une fraude massive
on ne voit pas par quel moyen se
permettent de passer un coup ko en tout
cas le candidat de du parti au pouvoir
mohamed bazoum lui est plutôt confiant
on l'a entendu tout à l'heure y a quand
même ses détracteurs lui lui lui
reprochent justement de ne pas être
nigérien d'origine pourquoi selon la
constitution ne pourrait pas être le
futur président du niger est ce que vous
vous partager l'avis de ses détracteurs
mais d'abord le premier point c'est que
la coupe nationale qui a validé sa
qualité tueur contre la constitution
dont l'article 41 de la constitution se
base en fait qu'il n'est pas bien
monsieur gazon ou au centre de la
constitution j'entends et d'adrien
d'origine il faut être né au niger deux
parents au moins un parent né au niger
égard il ne remplit pas ces conditions
il le sait parfaitement
non seulement il le sait parfaitement
mais il a produit des documents qui sont
pratiquement clairement faux et malgré
tout ça il a été lui même est validé
donc ça c'est une inquiétude majeure que
le pouvoir en voir sur la capacité de la
cour constitutionnelle à ça être juge et
impartiale c'est un point
de notre point de vue c'est vrai qu'on
peut quand même s'étonner parce que ça
n'a pas empêché en tout cas mohamed
bazoum de occupé le poste de ministre de
l'intérieur
durant des années d'avoir même était à
plusieurs élections au regard des enjeux
sécuritaires vitaux pour la population
il l'avenir de votre pays est ce que
cette question n'avait de la nationalité
justement de mohamed bazoum elle elle
n'est pas dérisoire
ça n'a rien à voir il a été très
clairement explicité que c'est le poste
de président de la république
personne n'a jamais parlé de la
nationalité d'eva zoom lorsqu'il était
bis appui des rues peel ce qui vaut
aussi bien que personne n'a un compte
personnel vis-à-vis de lui mais au
niveau de l'art de la constitution en
vigueur aujourd'hui il n'est pas
possible d'être éligible à la présidence
de la république on ne remplit pas un
certain nombre de conditions liées à la
nationalité
ce poste uniquement si mohamed bazoum
remporté les scrutins présidentiels ou
du moins si les finalistes pour un
second tour
que se passera-t-il est ce qu'il faut
craindre à une très forte contestation
nous nous avons très bien aujourd'hui
que le ps ne peut en aucune manière
gagner ces élections au premier tour en
aucune manière si ce n'est que par une
fraude massive et l'opposition acceptera
peur et que le peuple nigérien lève le
traiteur ça au moins c'est quelque chose
de très clair dans la droite est
aujourd'hui c'est un pouvoir qui a été
quasiment désavoué par beaucoup de gens
commencent et d'avoir par leur propre
camp monsieur base ont fait campagne
présidentielle on n'a jamais vu un seul
un seul leader du pds l'accompagner dans
la cité l'éducation comme ça montre bien
que même au sein de leur propre camp ils
ont du mal à l'onu mal à convaincre
est-ce que la contestation
fera dans la rue une contestation
radicale c'est à cela à quoi il faut
s'attendre
écoutez moi je ne nous sommes nous
sommes des gens pacifiques
nous avons utilisé toutes les toutes les
procédures pour éviter en tout cas de le
prolonger la la souffrance du top donc
ou non en a une
un observatoire unifiée de l'ancien de
l'opposition on suit pas à pas tout ce
qui est tout ce qui est dépouillement et
qu'elles ont tant de résultats
je pense que c'est une question que nous
allons régler à ce niveau là ici ils
cherchent un passage en force
la smala ça je sais que nous ne pouvons
pas aller regarder les drapeaux
évidemment merci beaucoup à vous amadou
boubacar cissé ex premier ministre du
niger